le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais de nos jours trouver un
emploi devient très difficile on a donc
souvent envie de tenter sa chance
ailleurs que ce soit dans une autre
région ou dans un are pays mais où que
nous soyons la nécessité de trouver un
travail est primordiale pour tenir à nos
besoins beaucoup de jeunes réunionnés
veulent se former pour obtenir de
l'expérience et ainsi accéder à un
travail mais malheureusement le marché
de l'emploi est souvent saturé dans
beaucoup de secteurs alors comment
obtenir une formation hors de la Réunion
qui accompagne ces jeunes motivé dans
leur démarche de mobilité on en parle
maintenant dans lien
social depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
Kevin un jeune réunionné est à la
recherche d'un emploi
par le biais d'Internet il a appris que
l'un des partenaires du knnarm proposait
une formation de boucher après avoir
passé un entretien avec les dirigeants
du knnarm il a eu l'opportunité de
suivre une formation dans la grande
distribution je voulais faire ce métier
en sortant de la 3è mava pas accepté
donc j'ai tenté ma chance aujourd'hui
j'ai découvert cette formation via
internet j'ai posé une demande à laarme
puis j'ai passé un entretien avec un
gérant de la grande distribution qui
m'avait confirmé la première étape la
deuxème étape je l'ai fait dans une
grande distribution pendant 2 semaines
et après les 2 semaines on a passé un
entretien pour savoir C favorable ou pas
c'était favorable et on attend de voir
la suite au niveau de mon stage pendant
les de semaines ça s'est bien passé j'ai
j'ai compris j'ai capté assez facilement
ce qu'il m'ont demandé j'ai fait les
étapes j'étais assez minutieux assez
ordonné et j'ai fait ce qu'on m'avait
demandé je suis prêt à faire ma
formation en métropole il y a pas de
souci comme Kevin
est un JEE motivé et plein d'ambition
qui a pu bénéficier de ce stage grâce au
RSMA mon chef de section a un contact
avec le gérant de
métropole grand distribution et j'ai
postulé dedans et puis ça ça bien pass
j'ai fait l'entretien
à et puis il m'ont donné de semaines de
stage supermarché déjà j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses et en
particulièrement les poissons mettre le
poissons sur les tables faire des murs
et puis mes difficultés c'était juste à
taper les codes déjà j'ai eu un avis de
favorable j'étais content
et content et puis reste à venir quand
je veux partir en métropole je suis prêt
à quitter à la Réunion pour découvrir un
métier qui qui me plaît et postuler
dedans et mettre à fond toutes mes
qualités après avoir passé de semaines
dans le groupe Casino Kevin et Claudie
ont pu bénéficier d'un contrat
d'apprentissage dans le sud de la France
le knarme et le Conseil Général aident
de nombreux réunionnés à la recherche
d'un emploi ou d'une formation et qui
souhaitent partir en métropole ou
ailleurs pour poursuivre leurs études en
travaillant en collaboration avec des
sociétés de la grande distribution les
jeunes peuvent bénéficier d'une
formation avec des professionnel en les
accompagnant le knarm et le Conseil
Général leur offrent le billet d'avion
un hébergement et un contrat
d'apprentissage dès leur arrivée nous
avons assisté ce matin à une opération
qui est d'abord exemplaire et qui
s'avère utile puisqu'il s'agit pour 12
réunionnés d'aller apprendre un médecer
en métropole dans un grand groupe de la
grande distribution par le billet de
contrat d'alternance ces jeunes à la
Réunion sont aujourd'hui à la recherche
d'emploi ils ont la possibilité
d'apprendre un métier euh dans un groupe
international qui leur garanti un emploi
au terme de
leur apprentissage euh donc c'est une
opération extrêmement valorisante qui a
pu se faire grâce évidemment à
l'opérateur PARM grâce au moyen du
conseil général grâce au groupe Casino
et aussi grâce à nos partenaires que
sont le RSMA le Pôle Emploi l'émission
local l'étoile de la deuxième chance
tout ce mond là s'est mis ensemble pour
sélectionner 12 jeunes motivés qui vont
sauter la mer pour aller apprendre un
métier occuper un emploi c'est
formidable le groupe Casino a recruté
avec l'aide duupnarme 12 jeunes
réunionnés pour des contrats
d'apprentissage sur les métiers de
bouche dont boucher et poissonnier le
knnarm les aide pour leur mobilité en
ayant identifié l'entreprise et en
prenant en charge t les frais plus les
frais d'installation le contrat
d'apprentissage sera effectué dans un
des magasins du groupe dans le sud de la
France à l'issue de ce contrat le groupe
s'est engagé à embaucher ses jeunes en
CDI en métropole ou à la Réunion s'il le
souhaite le Conseil Général de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général au côté
réunionnais